Socrates is considered the father of Western
philosophy.
He was a man who questioned everything and
everyone.
With no regard for how his opinions would
be received, he imposed his views with a dogmatic
superiority that sealed his eventual fate.
Sill, his great legacy to the world was the
method of questioning to arrive at the truth
known as the Socratic method.
Today on Biographics, we discover the man
who was Socrates.
Beginnings
Of all the great figures of antiquity, none
are as frustrating for the historian as Socrates.
The man never wrote down anything that has
survived, so the only records of his life
come from secondary sources.
The two main ones are from Plato, his devoted
student, and Xenophon, a contemporary of Plato.
These writings mainly consist of records of
conversations that often included Socrates
himself.
Discerning the facts of his life from such
writings is a challenge.
In fact, this lack of solid biographical information
is known as the Socratic problem.
Socrates was either born in 469 or 470 B.C.E.
in a Greek village located a twenty-minute
walk away from Athens.
His father, Sophroniscus, was a sculptor while
his mother, Phaenarete, worked as a mid-wife.
Sophroniscus wanted his son to take on the
craft of a sculptor so, during his youth,
he was apprenticed to his father.
He apparently became an accomplished sculptor
with tradition having it that he worked on
a well-known statue entitled the Three Muses
in Their Habits, which was on display at the
Acropolis.
As a young man, Socrates, devoured the writings
of the Greek philosopher Anaxagoras.
It is believed that he may have actually studied
under this master but that cannot be determined
with certainty.
The basic teaching of Anaxagoras were that
all things have always existed, but in their
original form were in tiny fragments of their
current form.
In Athens, the Agora, or public square, was
the central meeting place for men to discuss
politics, art and philosophy.
As he was still a youth, Socrates was not
eligible to attend the Agora.
Instead he spent much of his free time in
the workshops of the city’s merchants where
he would engage them in philosophical questions.
After some time working as a sculptor, Socrates
went off to study under the philosophical
master Archelaus.
He studied mathematics and astronomy and became
familiar with the work of earlier philosophers.
According to a 3rd Century biographer by the
name of DiogenesLaertius, Archelaus embarked
upon a homosexual relationship with Socrates,
a practice which was widespread in ancient
Greece.
At the time that Socrates began showing an
interest in philosophy, the discipline was
about a hundred years old.
The ideas that were being thrown around were
largely theoretical, bearing little practical
application.
Socrates soon came to the realization that
the things that he was learning didn’t have
any benefit to society.
He was far more interested in addressing the
problems of everyday life.
Despite his curiosity to understand the world
he was not a scientific thinker.
Rather than questioning the world to understand
how it worked, he believed that we would be
better off questioning ourselves in order
to understand how we work.
He adopted the quote which has often been
wrongly attributed to him – Know Thyself.
The Soldier-Philosopher
With the outbreak of the Peloponnesian War
in 431 B.C.E, Socrates was recruited as a
hoplite, the equivalent of a private, third
class.
He immediately stood out among his fellow
conscripts.
Even though there is much discrepancy about
the details of his life, there is one thing
about Socrates upon which there is universal
agreement – he was ugly.
He had a snub nose and his hair was long and
unkempt.
He also showed no interest in personal grooming
and rarely bathed.
We know about Socrates’ military service
from the writings of Plato.
In Plato’s work, Apology, he tells us that
his master fought in the battles of Amphipolis,
Delium and Potidaea.
Another chronicler, Alcibiades, specifically
mentions Socrates’ heroic actions in the
Battle of Delium, stating that the philosopher
saved his life during the fighting.
Having completed his military service, in
406 B.C.E., Socrates was appointed as a member
of the boule, which was a 500-member council
which ran the daily affairs of Athens.
Xenophon tells us that he was the overseer
of a debate held to determine the fates of
a number of military commanders who had abandoned
their wounded in battle in order to pursue
the Spartans.
The public were clamoring for the men to be
put to death, but Socrates blocked the vote
and the men’s lives were spared.
Challenging Society
With the end of the Peloponnesian war in 404
BC, there was a period of upheaval in Athens
that resulted in the coming to power of a
group known as the Thirty Tyrants.
These men instituted a period of terror marked
by bloodshed and confiscation of property.
After eight months, the rebel regime fell
and was replaced with a democratic Greek government,
but that hardly meant that life was going
to get better for Socrates.
In fact, it was about to get a whole lot worse.
Socrates was an opponent of democracy.
He believed that the people as a whole were
incapable of self-rule.
They needed a wise shepherd to guide them
in life.
He further claimed that the ordinary citizen
does not possess any innate virtue that would
give him the ability to speak on behalf of
others.
Virtue, he maintained, was something that
is attained only by knowledge and that knowledge
was beyond the scope of the everyday person.
These ideas were sharply at odds with those
of the Athenian society in which Socrates
lived.
The people cherished the enlightened right
of every citizen to have a voice in the assembly.
As a result, the ideas of Socrates were viewed
with suspicion, if not outright hostility.
Things weren’t helped by the rather condescending
and arrogant manner in which he expressed
his views.
He was dismissive of those who held contrary
views to his own.
This frequently led to violent reactions.
Diogenes records that . . .
"men set upon him with their fists or tore
his hair out,".
Faced with this, Socrates "bore all this ill-usage
patiently."
A fascinating contemporary view of Socrates
is provided by the Athenian comic playwright
Aristophanes.
In 423 B.C.E, he wrote a play called The Clouds.
In that play he has a character who is clearly
based on Socrates.
This character, the headmaster of a ‘thinkery’,
is presented as a comic buffoon who ‘stalks
the streets’ barefoot, looking down his
nose at the ignorant masses and ‘rolling
his eyes’ at the unintelligible guttural
that he hears.
Socrates was apparently friendly with Aristophanes
and held no grudge against such portrayals.
In fact, Plutarch quotes him as saying the
following . . .
When they break a jest upon me in the theatre,
I feel as if I were at a big party of good
friends.
It appears, then, that, around the 420’s
Socrates was seen by most people as a local
oddball, who was slightly annoying but generally
harmless.
But that view was to change.
The democracy that Athenians so cherished
was challenged on two occasions during Socrates’
later years.
During a four-month period in 411-410 B.C.E.
Athenian democracy was overthrown.
Then in 404 B.C.E the Thirty Tyrants usurped
democracy, ushering in eight months of chaos.
Both of these insurrections were led by former
students of Socrates, Alcibiades and Critias,
relatives of Plato.
The first of these insurrections turned public
opinion against Socrates as the brains behind
the coup.
With the bloodshed caused by the second overthrow,
people began to indirectly blame the philosopher
for the carnage.
With the coming to power of the Thirty Tyrants,
the former leaders of the democracy fled to
the mountains.
There they planned their resistance.
The elders of the new totalitarian government
did not directly involve Socrates in the carrying
out of their wicked acts – except on one
occasion.
They summoned him along with four other men
and ordered them to go to Salamis and apprehend
a learned man of influence by the name of
Leon and then bring him back to Athens to
be executed.
This man was an upstanding, honest citizen
who had done nothing deserving of condemnation,
let alone death.
Socrates refused to do this dirty work, stating
that he would never perform an act that compromised
his integrity.
However, he did nothing to warn Leon of the
impending danger.
As a result, the other four men went ahead
and apprehended Leon and he was summarily
put to death.
This failure to pro-actively warn Leon would
come back to haunt Socrates at his upcoming
trial.
Rather than being viewed as the local eccentric,
Socrates was now being seen by many as a dangerous
spreader of radical ideas that were leading
others to the most vile excesses.
By 403 B.C.E the rule of the Thirty Tyrants
was over and the former democratic government
had been restored.
A general amnesty had been enacted which meant
that no-one, including Socrates, could be
brought up on charges for their actions during
the eight months
of tyranny.
Trial
Socrates was finally arrested in 399 BCE.
By then the state had four years since the
end of the last revolt to come up with some
charges against him.
During that period Socrates appeared to be
undeterred by the return to favor of democracy
and the antipathy towards those who espoused
views in opposition to it.
He continued to deride democracy and to champion
rule by a strong leader.
When there was another attempted overthrow
in 401, the state had had enough of his revolutionizing
of impressionable youth.
It was now just a matter of time before he
was brought to account.
Athenian law allowed for any citizen to bring
criminal proceedings against another.
A man named Meletus brought an oral summons
against Socrates.
The summons required him to appear before
a legal magistrate to face charges of impiety
and of corrupting youth.
The magistrate heard out the applicant and
determined that there were grounds for a preliminary
hearing.
At that hearing the charges were read out
and Socrates was given the opportunity to
answer them.
A document containing the charges was then
drawn up, long with the requested penalty.
It read . . .
Socrates is guilty of refusing to recognize
the gods recognized by the state, and of introducing
new divinities.
He is also guilty of corrupting the youth.
The penalty demanded is death.
The actual trial took place over a period
of nine hours in the Agora in the center of
Athens.
The jury was made up of 500 citizens, drawn
by lot.
The large hury number was standard in Ancient
trials and seems to have been mainly to prevent
bribery from swaying the outcome of cases.
After the reading of the charges, the three
main accusers of Socrates were given three
hours to present their case.
There is no surviving record of their testimony.
We do know, however, that the main accuser
was not Meletus, but a certain Anytus, whom
was a politician who harbored ongoing resentments
against Socrates.
It is believed that the son of Antyus was
a student with whom Socrates had a homosexual
relationship, something which greatly upset
the father.
It is likely that the main thrust of the accusations
was that Socrates was leading young people
down a dangerous political path with his anti-democratic
teachings.
However, in Plato’s Apology, in which he
provides an account of Socrates’ defense,
considerable weight is given to his defense
of the charge of impiety.
Piety in those days involved not only respect
for the Greek Gods, but also for the dead
and for one’s ancestors.
If there was even one impious person in the
city, it was a serious matter, as that one’s
incursions might bring the wrath of the Gods
upon the entire city.
Even though the Athenians had no written scriptural
code and no priesthood, there were a significant
number of rituals, observances and offerings
that were required.
It is highly likely that Socrates neglected
to observe the rituals of the Gods that would
have been expected of him.
Furthermore, he would have argued that the
generally accepted view of worship as being
based on rituals was wrong.
According to Xenophon, Socrates claimed to
have the ability to communicate directly with
the gods.
This would have infuriated those in attendance
at his trial, including the 500 jurors.
It is difficult for us to know just what,
if any, religious beliefs, Socrates actually
held.
Throughout his dialogues, Plato has him referring
to both one God and to gods.
It has also been suggested that he viewed
the word God as referring to the philosophical
idea of goodness.
A critical part of the accusations against
him had to do with his close association with
the leaders of the Thirty Tyrants rebellion,
specifically his ties to the leader of the
revolt, Critias.
In his defense, Socrates brought up the time
when he was ordered to go and arrest Leon
of Salamis.
He claimed that his refusal to do so was a
clear indication that he was not in cahoots
with the rebels and was, instead, a loyal
citizen of Athens.
But his accuser countered that a loyal citizen
would have done more than simply refrain from
the bad action; he would have warned the innocent
man and, therefore, saved his life.
Socrates spoke in his own defense for three
full hours.
Of the dozens of versions of it that were
made, only two have survived down to our time
– those of Plato and Xenophon.
The versions agree that the master was defiant
in his tone, almost as if he were inviting
an adverse judgement.
As part of his defense, Socrates told the
jurors that he was a hero.
He recalled his exemplary military service.
He then extended the thought with an analogy,
telling them he had fought for decades to
save the souls of young Athenians.
If teaching virtue made him guilty of corruption,
he said then was guilty as charged.
He then assured his listeners with the following
. . .
Men of Athens, I honor and love you; but I
shall obey God rather than you, and while
I have life and strength I shall never cease
from the practice and teaching of philosophy.
In the face of the charge that he was a corrupter
of the youth of Athens, Socrates stated that
he never claimed to be a teacher.
He was merely a man who happened to spend
time strolling around the city.
If he was asked a question, he would answer
it to the best of his ability.
Then, pointing to Plato and others of his
followers in the crowd he pointed out that
none of them had ever laid an accusation against
him.
Those of his former students who had done
bad, he said, did so because they corrupted
the things that he had said.
As the marathon speech drew to a close it
was obvious to everyone listening that Socrates
had no intention of stopping doing whatever
it was that people objected to.
The only way to stop him was to put him to
death.
Contrary to normal practice in such proceedings,
he made no pleas for mercy.
After nine hours of proceedings, the jury
of 500 were tasked with, making their decision.
Unlike today, the jury did not retire to discuss
their thoughts.
They simply voted by placing a disk into one
of two urns, labelled guilty or not guilty,
with the urn that had held the most votes
determining the outcome.
Once they had all completed this task, there
were 280 disks in the guilty urn and 220 in
the not guilty one.
The jury’s job was not yet over.
Now they had to determine the penalty.
They accusers of Socrates rose and put forward
their case that the condemned impious corrupter
of the youth of Athens must be put to death.
Socrates himself was then invited to put forward
his case for leniency.
This was his opportunity to win some favor
with the jury, perhaps by suggesting that
he be sent into exile.
But, true to his nature, he refused to step
down from his position of superior indignation.
He should, he suggested, be rewarded rather
than condemned for his actions.
The court officials were not impressed and
he was told to give a more realistic alternative
penalty.
Socrates then offered that he could be subjected
to a modest fine.
Faced with these two extremes of punishment,
the jurors chose death.
The Death of Socrates
With the trial now over, Socrates was taken
to an adjoining prison cell.
According to the record of his final days
penned by Plato, Socrates was given the opportunity
to escape when he was visited in his cell
by his wealthy friend Crito.
This man had already laid plans to smuggle
Socrates out of Athens.
However, the condemned man showed no interest
in escaping his fate.
The conversation between the two men, as Crito
attempted to persuade Socrates to escape,
and the great philosopher’s responses present
an important aspect of Socrates’ moral code.
Crito put forward three points as to why Socrates
should escape from his death sentence.
Firstly, the death would be a bad reflection
on the followers of Socrates, as people would
think that they abandoned him.
Secondly, all finances involved in the escape
were covered and, furthermore, a comfortable
life in exile had been arranged.
Finally, his death would leave his sons without
a father.
In response, Socrates countered that a man
should not worry about public opinion, but
only be guided wisdom.
The only real question to consider in the
situation was where or not it was just for
Socrates to escape his condemnation to death.
He then spoke of the Laws of Athens, stating
that to break one of those laws meant breaking
all of them.
To go against the laws of Athens would be
like a child rebelling against a parent, he
argued.
If he were to dare to go against the laws
of the city, he asserted, he would receive
a harsh judgment in the underworld.
As a result, Socrates refused the offer of
escape.
His fate was now sealed.
Plato chronicles his death in his work . In
it he gives an eyewitness account from the
viewpoint of fictional character Phaedo.
According to the account, a man came into
the cell carrying a cup of poisoned hemlock.
Socrates turned to him and said . . .
Now good sir, you understand these things.
Tell me what I must do.
The man replied . . .
Just drink it and walk around until your legs
begin to feel heavy, then lie down.
It will soon act.
The cup was then offered to Socrates.
He took it happily, and then asked if it was
permissible for him to offer a pledge before
drinking it.
Permission was granted, and he offered the
following prayer . . .;
we can and must pray to the gods that our
sojourn on earth will continue happy beyond
the grave.
This is my prayer, and may it come to pass.
At this he drank the poison without hesitation.
Those of his friends who were in the cell
with him gave way to tears, prompting Socrates
to declare . . .
You are strange fellows; what is wrong with
you?
I sent the women away for this very purpose,
to stop their creating such a scene.
I have heard that one should die in silence.
So please be quiet and keep control of yourselves.
For the next few minutes he walked around
the room.
Then, when his legs became heavy, he lay on
his bed with a covering over his face.
Slowly he lost feeling, first in his legs
and then moving up his body.
His last words, directed to Crito, were . . .
Crito, we owe a cock to Asclepius.
Do pay it.
Don't forget.
This seems a rather strange request.
But it makes sense when we realize that Asclepius
was the God of Good Health.
The sacrifice of a cock was a normal offering
of thanks for recovery from illness.
Socrates believed that he was cured of the
disease of life and was, as a result, not
frightened of death.
Crito then asked him if there was anything
else, he wanted to say.
But there was no reply.
The poison had reached his heart and the life
of Socrates was drained away.
Plato concluded his account with these words
. . .
This was the end of our friend, the best,
wisest and most upright man of any that I
have ever known.